première fois depuis le 14 avril que
kiev est touché et que des endroits près
du centre ville de kiev ça fait depuis
le début du mois d'avril sinon même le
mois de mars je pense que cette frappe
passait le plus proche du centre-ville
de kiev qui a été touchée en fait depuis
le début de l'invasion
principalement c'est l'immeuble que vous
voyez derrière moi qui a été touchée il
y a eu des incendies à d'autres
immeubles aussi à proximité
mais comme vous voyez l'immeuble est
très fortement endommagée il ya des
dizaines de villes de fenêtres brisées
on parle seulement de 4 pardon de cinq à
dix blessés la raison de cela c'est
parce que c'est un immeuble neuf et la
plupart des appartements n'étaient pas
encore habitées alors il y avait peu de
gens qui se trouvaient à l'immeuble au
moment de la frappe sinon je pense que
n'auraient pu avoir des dégâts humains
bien plus importante bonjour gulliver
antonio goûter rsa a reconnu
l'impuissance de l'onu dans ce conflit
on sait qu'il est actuellement à kiev
oui on se demande si cette fable sur le
centre de kiev pendant sa présence
c'était est justement
l'ex prix de la russie qui voulait
qu'ils voulaient souligner cette
impuissance si vous voulez des nations
unies si si la frappe avait une valeur
symbolique cela c'est possible aussi que
la frappe était pour cibler un cible que
les russes estimé stratégiques ou
militaire on ne sait pas exactement
quelle était la cible si cet immeuble là
c'était vraiment la cible ou s'ils ont
raté la vraie cible tout cela est
difficile à savoir en tout cas antonio
gutiérrez a dit qu'il était choqué et
cela faisait suite à son aveu de
l'impuissance du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies qui l'a dit n'a pas tu
n'as pas été en mesure de stopper cette
invasion russe et c'est aussi le
président volodymyr zelensky ukrainien
qui a critiqué le conseil de sécurité
des nations unies ou quand on a un
belligérant la russie qui est aussi un
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies et qui peut donc
opposer son veto à toute décision
clairement c'est un problème structurel
pour que le conseil puisse avoir une
action efficace pour la résolution de ce
conflit